so we'll start again with let's start
from the drill comes in time in back
foot and we'll do the weight shift
okay so we're working on the timing
accepting luck with that bring back your
venture and then tie it back oh you can
do a corner you just do the release it
hits the ball immediately I don't play
with it
okay you can move a little ball move or
work or you're out
hundred ox so my arm is wished you
squeeze it squeeze it you see its
mission I don't have to be like mushy
but you still can't pinch mark which are
usually you sure there aren't squeeze it
it doesn't matter okay so I go in okay
so now your mind is here and we have to
think about it differently
okay so we have to one where I came to
the elbow right and then you can do this
thing
this one taken to the elbow
oh you take them up to the shoulder -
boom wow I could rig move in any lunar
touch my chest I can do the other one -
when I want to get an idea that wherever
there's whatever touching you can do it
- thank you so whatever I touch doesn't
bother whatever it touches doesn't
matter doesn't matter okay so we'll go
back to the keep on we're going to work
on the weight shifting shield or yield
so clear okay so a long ball now ice
here but I'm not going to do that it's
the same projection
[Music]
the left foot for gender it's not me
here trying to wrestle him down it's the
same projection cheering faint
projection now faint projection here
doesn't change this when I was doing the
other girls he is tasked with pushing
straight and so his task already sets up
my rear foot okay
this technique is more dynamic so where
is the Kazushi yes I need the Kazushi
pattern in his body
tilt it and get the X pattern to his hip
but it has to happen at a place where
this foot can be the vector for this
throw this wait I'm going to grab that
you're off can't be put anywhere nor can
I move is bottom anywhere it all goes
together so here I have to put it where
you can do it
see this but it's too far over now I'm
just shoving a guy down
[Music]
so pay attention to where you generate
the angle and where that push is going
to be on that mass go where it needs to
go so this is always wrong Hey so all
your might we do by Petrillo it's the
chemo moth has been corrupted your super
tanks so let's play with it
[Music]